(light upbeat music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the "Addy Hour."
I'm honored to be able to continue hosting
these conversations and
glad that you all are here
for episode 30 of this podcast.
It's hard for me to
believe that we're already
on episode 30.
We've had so many guests,
great guests come through,
and that's definitely
the case today as well.
I was saying before we jump
down that these are my heroes
in some sense.
So I'm gonna try and hold back,
but I have a lot of excitement
and just the opportunity
to have both of these
individuals on the podcast today.
And we're gonna be talking
about faith, community
and mental health partnerships.
So it's my absolute pleasure to be able
to welcome Dr. Ayana Jordan
and Dr. Sidney Hankerson
to the "Addy Hour" podcast.
Thanks so much to both
of you for being here.
- Happy to be here.
When you call, we answer.
We're here for you.
- Fabulous.
- Oh my goodness, I appreciate that.
Well, like I said, these
are my heroes in some sense.
So I gotta go ahead and give
them a little bit introduction
to introduce you all as listeners
to just the great pioneering
work that they've done.
I'm gonna go ahead and
start with Dr. Jordan.
Dr. Ayana Jordan is an
addiction psychiatrist
and the Barbara Wilson Associate
Professor in of Psychiatry
in the Department of Psychiatry
at the NYU Grossman School of Medicine.
She is also the pillar lead
for the community engagement
in the NYU Langone Institute
of Excellence in Health Equity.
Dr. Jordan is someone who is
dedicated to creating spaces
and opportunities for
more people of color,
specifically black women in academia
who are vastly underrepresented.
Dr. Jordan is someone who
has a lot of accolades
and has been involved in a lot
of different pioneering
things over the years.
I'm just gonna highlight a few of them,
want to mention that she was
the first black associate
program director for the Yale University
of Psychiatry Residency
program when she was
on faculty at Yale for quite a while.
She recently also became
the Director of Equity,
Diversity and Inclusion
for the Justice Community
Opioid Innovation Network.
She also serves as the medical director
for the Recognizing and
Eliminating disparities
of an Addiction through
Culturally informed Healthcare
or REACH.
These are funded programs
that she has garnered.
So that's something that we
don't take for granted at all.
She's also an NIH funded researcher
where she studies the long term outcomes
for providing addiction
treatment in face settings.
Something that we're going
to dig into today as well.
And just to wrap up and say,
she's someone who's deeply
grateful to be taking care
of the most historically excluded
patients during this time
who are facing extreme challenges
in obtaining addiction treatment,
even as we continue to
walk through the pandemic.
So someone who again is a pioneer
and I'm just honored to
be able to welcome her
to the program and to
introduce you all as listeners
to the wonderful, talented,
inspiring and wise,
Dr. Ayana Jordan.
- Hey me, listen, have me back anytime.
I'm like, that was an amazing intro!
I just wanna walk away now, but thank you.
Thank you.
Asha, brother, so much love.
- Yeah, definitely appreciate you.
To also introduce Dr. Sidney Hankerson.
Dr. Hankerson is the Director
of Mental Health Equity Research
at Mount Sinai in the Institute
for Health Equity Research.
He is someone who has also
garnered many different grants.
He's been awarded grants
from National Institute
of Mental Health, the Brain
and Behavior Foundation,
and the New York State
Office of Mental Health.
He was formerly at Columbia University,
had funding through there as well,
and has also been involved
in many funding sources
from private foundations.
He's someone who was presented
in lots of different venues,
including the White House,
including the United Nations,
at the National Institute
of Mental Health.
Also the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services Administration.
Also at Gracie Mansion,
also known as the New
York City mayor's office,
has just been involved in the community
in so many different ways over the years.
He was also an inaugural member
of the American Psychiatric
Association's Council of Faith
and Community Partnership,
and has served on the APA Council
of Minority Mental Health Disparities.
He's someone who is just deeply
invested in the community
and also in integrating aspects
of mental health services
and faith communities as well.
And something that I know again,
that's gonna be just an important part
of today's conversation.
So again, my apologies for just being
so overly enthusiastic,
but these are people who
have just been pioneers
in the field for so many different,
in so many ways over the years.
And especially as Black physicians,
I just have to highlight
the excellence with
which they're doing the
work and the role models
that they are as well.
So again, you can tell I'm excited,
but I just had to be able to
give credit where credit is due
and grateful for both
of them, to both of them
for being here in this moment.
So thanks again.
- No, thank you Nii, thank
you for the opportunity
and the space.
- Of course.
Well, as my listeners know,
I think it's always important
for us just to be able
to check in with each other
and see how we all are doing.
So, even as you all have done
so many important things that
we celebrate, we also
do know that the work
that you do is critically important.
And we know that there's a
backdrop of just challenges that
we've been facing in this society.
We're recording this at the end of May.
We've, you know, continued to experience
so many different shootings across
this country in Buffalo,
in California, in Texas
at an elementary school.
And we know that there are other
things that have been going
on that aren't even
highlighted in the media.
And so we do take time to pause, you know,
to be able to mourn and
to be able to reflect,
and then also to call ourselves to action.
But just in the context of all of that,
I just wanted to check in with both of you
and just see how you all are
doing at this point in time,
especially with the work
that you're already doing
within mental health and thinking
about how we're processing
this as a society.
So Ayana if we could start
with you, that'd be wonderful.
- Yeah, I appreciate
you really centering all
that has happened just in
the past couple of weeks
and really being very deliberate
in checking in because
in so many of the spaces
that I have been in, I have
been the one checking in
with others because many
people just wanna go on
with business as usual.
And I'm like, pause, literally
like pump the breaks.
There is so much trauma right now,
and I have never ever, thank God really,
I'm very grateful as by the grace of God,
I've never had a, you know,
serious mental illness that
I've had to really deal with,
but I can tell you psychologically,
it has been very difficult
for me to do my work
because I am constantly
thinking about safety.
What places are safe,
you know, as a woman,
as a Black woman, oftentimes
I think about safety in terms
of where do I park my car?
Where do I work?
Where do I live, but
extending that now to babies,
my nieces and my nephew,
worshiping like what
place is sacred, right?
And so in a way that I
didn't really understand why
it impacted me so much until
I went to my own therapist.
I'm in therapy every Tuesday at 11.
I'm very clear about that
because I realize that
there's just not a sense of safety, right?
And so I have to grapple with that reality
and it's just been really difficult.
And so I really appreciate
you checking in.
And I, this to me was actually
restorative because I said,
I know that I'm going to be
in a space amongst people
that I trust to really talk through some
of these key issues,
because none of us are
protected against feeling
the very real pain of what is happening.
And so even if we're not in it directly,
this whole idea of vicarious
trauma is very real.
And so I've just given myself grace.
I've canceled meetings.
I've said to my team
like, listen, take time.
And if you're not okay,
I need you to be well,
because we can't do the
work of really trying
to liberate black folks. (laughs)
You know, that's the point of
Jordan Wellness Collaborative,
and really trying to liberate people
who have been totally
desecrated and just ignored
from society if you're not well.
And yeah, I'm just mourning.
And I, you know, I checked in
with all of my loved ones just
to say, "I love you."
And just be very honest about
the reality of where we are in
this country and so,
yeah, it's been tough.
It's been tough.
And I appreciate you for checking in.
- Oh, of course.
I think it's so important,
to have that space.
And I mean, in many ways,
you've like you've said,
you're leading by example
because you're taking that time
for yourself and you're checking
in with those around you.
And I know just with all those
who are looking up to you,
I mean, I can speak
from personal experience
and seeing trainees look up to you,
see you take that time to pause
and that in a sense gives them permission
to also have that time
to pause, to have grace.
And so definitely appreciate
the ways you continue to do
that, even though it's not easy.
And the ways that you
lead by example as well.
- Yeah.
- What about you?
- Yeah, I'll say for me,
it's just been emotionally exhausting.
I think the Buffalo shooting
is especially poignant
to our, you know, conversation tonight
because so many of the people
that were killed were leaders
in their church.
A deacon, mothers, you know,
mothers of their churches.
It was devastating.
Elderly black folks murdered
in cold blood while shopping.
So I mean, it just really hit home for all
of the church members
and community members
that we work with.
It made me think about my parents.
It made me think about
just all of my mentors.
And I think to Ayana's point,
I've had a range of
emotions from rage to hatred
where this 18 year old who did this
and then published this manifesto
to just profound sadness,
to shock, to you know, you name it.
And I think then Tuesday
happens, right, in Texas.
And I think for me,
I have never felt as worried
for my kids as I did,
as I was reading those, the
articles about the story.
I remember like literally
walking outta my apartment.
It was my wife was bringing
our kids home from school
and I was just feverously
trying to look for them.
And I know that was just
out of just the terror
that something could happen to them.
And so it's just made me
feel tremendously vulnerable.
And also, you know, like
Ayana, I see a therapist.
I saw her today at nine.
So Thursday at nine is my session.
And it's been amazing
to process it with her
and also try to give the folks
in the community that we work
with time to process that,
cause it's been exhausting.
- Yeah, so true.
And again, just appreciate
your honesty because I think
in the same way as a leader,
others can see that, can hear
that and that can validate
those of all and just, you know,
the range of emotions that come.
And as I often share with people
sometimes multiple emotions
at once and just giving yourself
time to walk through that.
And just to be honest about the challenges
that poses for all of us.
I didn't know if there was
another point you wanted.
- Yeah, I was just, I was listening
to what Sidney was
saying about in Buffalo.
You know, so many of the
victims being involved
in their church, that being kind a,
really an important role in their lives
and last Thursday,
so the Thursday after
the shooting on the 19th,
I was at actually a community
event for Kathy Carroll,
who was one of my mentors
who passed away suddenly.
And we needed someone to pray, to bless,
raising money for a Kathy
Carroll Memorial Playground
so that the babies have somewhere to play.
And so we needed someone
to bless the space.
So I'm like, I know with
all these people out here,
we can find a praying
somebody, a pastor, a deacon,
somebody.
So I'm walking around
to elderly black folks
and one of the guys said, "I'm a pastor."
And I said, "thank you, pastor.(laughs)
Can you, you know, bless the space?"
And before he opened it up for prayer,
I felt like very compelled
to obviously hold space
for the victims of Buffalo.
And he said to me,
"I am so happy that you did that because
my cousin was murdered.
He was one of the victims.
- Wow.
- And I have just been
going and going and dealing
with the funeral plans and
he's a pastor, you know?
And he's like,
"this is the first time
that I've been able to like,
just take a breath and realize
like, this is really real."
And he got so emotional.
I got so emotional because here
I am, I was in Connecticut.
You know, I wasn't even thinking
that like I would run into,
I was just holding his space
because I've somehow felt
connected just for the trauma
of being Black and these people shopping.
But then it became very real,
like this is this man's
cousin, you know what I mean?
Like we are all interconnected.
And so that was really heavy, man.
You know what I mean?
Like this is not something
to do because it looks good
or sounds good.
Like a check-in is real, you know?
And I find myself seeing that we
as Black people are often checking in
and it's like do we do that because
we're mental health
professionals, we're trained
or do we do that because
we understand that we need
to see one another in a real way?
And for me, I think it's the latter,
'cause I've been in many
spaces where I being
the Black person has had to say, you know.
And so I just think that
speaks to a lot of what help
we get into today is our
collective resilience.
But also when is it going to
be our turn for others to check
in with us?
- Well said.
When will others check in on us?
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I mean to that question,
have you have either
of you seen a shift in that at all?
Does it still seem like
people are not fully aware?
Maybe it might not be
the best way to say it,
but just curious if you wanna elaborate
on your experience in that realm as well.
- I mean, I think that it can
be difficult for white people
to bring up issues.
They don't, I think it's
hard for them to initiate.
Some of my white friends have said,
"I didn't know how to say,
I wanted to say something.
I didn't know how."
And then, so there's that camp.
And then there's also some
folks that are just kind
of oblivious and just to Ayana's point,
just kind of going on business as usual.
So I think it, I've seen
kind of both extremes
and I do think it's
critical that we do pause,
but we also, and, you know,
give space to our white
colleagues to help them understand
that they need to be the ones
that initiate that instead
of always being Black folks.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think Sidney's right on point
because so Mondays I have lab meetings.
I try not to call my lab a lab.
It's the Jordan Wellness Collaborative,
but for you all, I call it
lab, but we're in a community.
It's not a lab 'cause of stigma.
Y'all got it.
But Mondays I have meetings with the team
and this was right after the shooting,
the Monday right after the shooting.
And I was lit, like I like
was literally sobbing.
I was literally sobbing because
just before the meeting.
I saw all the pictures of the
victims and like Syd said,
I was, Sidney was
saying, I was like, whoa,
this could have been my mom, my uncle.
Like I saw myself in so
many of these young people.
I mean these people,
but then I started to think
about the young people,
'cause I read about a
eight year old that hid
in the cooler so that
she wouldn't get shot.
That's the same age as my niece.
And so it, I just began to
sob in collective mourning
because it's like, how
much more can we take?
You already shot up
our churches, you know.
Any who, so I was sobbing
and people didn't know what was going on.
And I took a breath and
I said, "I'm going to,
we're not having this meeting.
Clearly I'm not in a place
to have this meeting,
but I am going to have
you all see the pictures
because this is someone's mother.
This is someone's aunt,
brother, sister, et cetera."
And a white woman that's
a part of my team.
She said, Ayana,
"thank you so much for doing this
because it didn't even hit me."
She's like "I heard about it."
But she's like, "you
know, I live in the suburb
around predominantly white people.
Like I read it and
thought, oh, that's that
and kept moving."
She said, "but not until
you showed the pictures,
said their names."
I said a little bit about them.
Like one, you know, was
a deacon in the church.
Just affirm their humanity
that she understand.
And she's like,
"I appreciate you doing
this because that helped me
to have more empathy and to pause."
But see it's the thing is like,
why do we have to show you that we matter.
And the way that these Latin brothers
and sisters were killed in
Texas, I didn't have to like,
like I was still affected by that.
I don't know them.
But it, see that's my humanity
because I know what it is, right.
But it's like, I just am so torn Sidney,
'cause Tiffany's right.
It's like we have to give our
white colleagues the space
to get it, but then I'm like,
but you should get it
because these are people.
But then I understand
that this is a collective
of them not valuing our lives, right.
- That's the message.
- Yeah and so important, like you said,
to bring that level of humanity.
And also, I've just seen unfortunately
because of how things have
been going the last few years,
people have even talking
about the opportunities
for us to unite as people, but different,
even different communities of color.
So as we had, you know, Rabbi
Buchdahl on the podcast,
a couple or the last episode,
talking about the hostage situation
that she helped navigate
at a synagogue in Texas
and all the things that she
could relate to on that front.
And then also the people of
color in her Jewish communities
who are also sharing about
their experiences, you know,
from mixed families,
Blacks who are also Jewish
and the things that they have felt,
which we can relate to as well
or when Juju Chang was talking
about all the anti-Asian hate
and how people had checked in with her.
But she hadn't necessarily
thought about checking in with
her African American
colleagues, same type of thing.
But then there was so much
that she could relate to.
So even in those circles, but again,
it's like you were saying,
even in those communities,
people can relate to the experience
and they're having easier time I think,
seeing a joint humanity.
But then when we, you know,
when we're talking about many of
our white brothers and sisters,
it's a different type of engagement.
So, Ayana like you
mentioned it's necessary,
but it's also challenging
because you don't want
to be the one to have to
bring that all the time.
And so I think, you know,
it's just something that's
important to be able
to hold that space and again,
just the way that you
have done that by example,
and being able to pull people in,
but then that can be exhausting
in and of itself, so.
- It is.
- Let me tell you something.
I tell my mentees this,
and it's something that like,
you know, sometimes it's like,
you gotta practice what you
preach and I haven't done that,
but I've honestly learned from Sidney
and I will shout him out
because one time I was,
I don't know something.
And he's like, "I am not
available, da, da, da,
I am my kids are," and I was like, listen,
like that to me was so
gangsta because I'm like, yes,
he is protecting him, access to him.
And then I had to learn
why am I not doing that?
Because for me, it's like,
oh no, I'm socialized to,
for people always to have
access to me, do this, do that.
But it's like, no, you
can protect your space.
So anyway, I tell my mentees
and I don't know where this came from,
but rest, resist, repeat.
Rest, resist, repeat.
And I am at my resting.
So on Monday I was like, I am out,
don't call me, don't
text me, don't email me.
Cause it is not getting so
I'm at a point where like,
even this weekend, like I
love my family, you know,
Black people, we love our
families for the most part,
but I was like, y'all can't stress me.
(Sidney laughing)
- I was supposed to
have the whole gang here
for the long holiday weekend.
And I was feeling just
so emotionally exhausted
from everything that we're talking about.
And I was like, I love
y'all, but Aunt Ayana,
the Connecticut home is
not happening, you know,
because I'm in this phase of rest
and I'm realizing that I have to do that
to protect my peace.
For all the Addy listeners in the podcast,
you guys are getting the what's it called,
exclusive 'cause I'm talking
to the y'all residents
for graduation.
And I was thinking about
what am I gonna say to them,
to and try to inspire
them during this time.
And the message that kept coming
to me was protect your peace.
So that's, I'm in a state
of rest and I will resist
because I really do think
that my identity in itself
is an act of political warfare.
So I have to resist.
But right now I'm in a period of rest
and Sidney showed me how
to do that and modeled.
And so I think that's important in terms
of the collective community.
You don't even realize
sometimes you're just moving.
How do you move in a
way and you don't know
that you have people looking at you?
So it's like, absolutely.
And so I'm so grateful.
So then Nii, you say, "Ayana,
can you do the podcast?"
Yes.
Now I don't know when I'm
gonna do it, but you know,
we're here.
I'm gonna do it because I believe in you,
brother, Black man.
I was so happy when I
got to Yale, I saw Nii.
I was like, who is this fine man?
Don't cuss me out to your wife,
who is professor at Yale?
(Syndey laughs)
I mean, I was so inspired.
I was a resident.
I was so happy.
You were an assistant professor
existing in that space.
And I was like, oh, this is amazing.
So I think that anyway,
it's just so important.
I'm so happy because it's
like we have to survive
because sometimes we don't even
realize who is watching us,
who we are impacting
by just modeling that.
And so I'm so grateful.
Like I truly, I really mean this
and I have to tell Sidney,
'cause I don't know if I already told him,
like I reached out to him years
ago when I was trying to do
my cade for the Black
Church Project to have,
and I don't wanna get emotional,
but I was like trying to figure this out
because so many people kept
saying, "you can't do this.
You cannot provide addiction treatment."
I have reached out to a PO and the NIH
and they just told me
like, "you can't do it."
You know?
And so I was just on the
strength of reaching out to him,
reading his papers and the space.
I'm like he modeled it and depression.
And like he was so helpful.
He would not only was he like,
"absolutely you can do this,"
but he's like, "what do you need?"
"You need my grant, you
need this, you need that."
It wasn't not like who are you?
He didn't know me.
I was nobody.
Like now I got a little piece of the pie,
but back then.
- You got a big piece
of the pie. (laughing)
- It's so important.
So it, for me, it comes full circle
because it's like we have to,
we don't have to, but I feel
I'll speak from a place that
I feel a collective responsibility
sometimes to be there
for investigators,
especially who are Black.
And in order to do that,
I am seeing more and more.
I have to protect my peace.
I have to have boundaries around me.
I have to have team members,
white people included that are going
to understand the importance of the work
that I'm gonna have to
model sometimes empathy,
how to build that empathy.
In order to be whole, I
need to take care of myself.
So that's why I have,
I get on good vacations
and I treat myself well.
And when I live in a
Harlem, my apartment is fly.
You know what I mean?
'Cause I have to protect my peace, yeah.
- Yeah, so well said.
I mean so many important pieces there too.
And like you said, I mean the
representation matters even
as you're trying to get,
as you were trying to get into the work
and get into the space.
I mean, I actually want to lean
into that a little bit too,
'cause as you talked about
even the way you said
you don't talk about lab
meeting in different settings,
'cause that stigma still is there,
especially when we think
about in our churches.
So, you know, for the listeners,
how did you all actually
create that space?
Because in the sense
you're leading by example,
but you also bring all that
institutional background
with you, for good or for bad.
And so how did you build that
trust to even have this kind
of integrated mental health
investment in faith communities
to even get that going?
Cause there's so many not to be,
there's so many areas where I feel like
that could get easily derailed,
but you've both done that with excellence.
So you, I'm just, if you
can share that, you know,
with our listeners as well.
- Sure, I'll go.
And then because I, and
then I think what Ayana did
is a hundred times more difficult
than what I did just because of,
because in the Black church,
at least growing up in the south,
there was more stigma I
think around substance use
and around like depression.
And so that's why I say what you did
I think was in many
respects more challenging
because of that.
You know, I kind of came
into this work, you know,
I grew up in the church, you know.
My dad's a deacon at Shiloh
Baptist Church, new site.
My mama played the piano
for the little kids choir
that we sang in.
So I was at choir rehearsal on Thursdays
and in service on Sundays.
Vacation Bible school during the summer.
Some of my best friends
are from the church,
my college roommate, just my
brother who went to Hampton.
- Shout out!
Shout out to the real HU!
I didn't know that.
(all laughing)
Ok.
- That's right.
So, and then so church provided a big part
of just community.
It grounded me in my blackness and it,
you know, provided the
foundation of my spiritual life.
And so I remember coming
up to New York in 2009
for a research fellowship
and knew that I wanted
to do something to help our people.
And I gave a talk at Greater
Allen AME Cathedral in Queens
about stigma and mental health.
And it was really well received
and that kind of developed a partnership
with the health ministry leader.
And we got a small grant,
a NARSAD Young Investigator Award.
And that was kind of my
entree into this space.
And so I think that it
really took just, you know,
we're a communal people, right?
So it just took being present.
It took being vulnerable.
It took, people had to know
that this was like my ministry
and not just my job.
You know, and I think to Ayana's point
about political warfare,
I completely agree with that.
And we really framed this
as a issue of social justice
in spiritual warfare.
And I think that resonated with folks.
- Wow.
- So that's kind of how
we, you know, started.
We did focus groups with pastors,
then we did depression screening
surveys with the PHQ-9.
Then we created
this community health
working training program,
recruiting folks from Black churches.
And that led to, you know,
our current, you know,
some of our current grants now.
So it was really one
church at a time building
those relationships, going
to ministry meetings,
doing a lot of presentations,
making a lot of referrals for people.
Cause I think folks had to
know that you're there for more
than just a grant or a
paper cause folks was tired
of the helicopter research, right.
They tired of folks
coming in doing something
and then leaving and not
giving anything back.
I think that it really took that trust
and being able to call out
institutionalized racism,
calling out psychiatric
misdiagnosis among Black men,
calling out, you know,
over criminalization
of black folks during the
cocaine epidemic and then,
you know, with opioids.
So being able to talk about
all of those social, cultural
and historical issues,
I think was critical.
- Yeah.
I mean just hearing you speak, I mean,
it sounds like you just
brought your whole self,
- Yes.
into those situations.
You were honest,
you were real about the
institutional challenges.
You were honest about the need.
You were building the trust.
So I mean, I would just get the sense
that people knew where
you were coming from.
They knew it was a place of sincerity.
It was a place where
you were trying to help.
And I imagine you, there probably
still was some hesitation
in some places, but I'm sure,
it sounds like you just,
you worked through that and
you addressed the big issues
that had to be addressed as well.
- Yeah and I think the key thing is,
and Ayana does this too,
is that just the community
based participatory approach.
Right, just having folks
from the community leading,
elevating community voices
and trusting them that
they know the answers
and the solutions and
just trusting the process.
And being a vessel to bring
their vision to light.
So I think that was just critical,
absolutely critical.
- Yeah, I appreciate you saying that.
I hope that resonates
with the listeners too,
just 'cause people who
are trying to wrestle
with the best way to kind
of approach these things,
just as you mentioned
elevate their voices.
- Right.
- Yeah and I think I, you know,
I appreciate the kind of
arc that Sidney presented,
but I also wanna just not
allow him to minimize kind
of the impact of the space, right.
Because it's really
thinking about like Jay-Z
and the "Blueprint."
First of all, I love hip hop.
So I always gonna think about
how to bring in hip hop.
Shout out to Kendrick Lamar's
album is so good right now.
But anyway, thinking about the "Blueprint"
because Sidney had already, for me anyway,
published in this area when
I had so many naysayers,
honestly, both from
academia, right, NIH, but,
and also people in the
church, Black people.
They were like, "you can't,
we ain't talking about"
One pastor was like, "I don't
got no addicts in my church.
What you trying to say?
I got addicts in my church."
And I was like, first of all,
I don't use that language,
but okay.
(both laughing)
But also I'm like just showing the stats.
I'm like people who misuse
substances are everywhere.
And I'm not saying that this is just you
or a reflection of you pastoring or not,
but I'm just anyway.
(both laughing)
But having to come in with
actual data to say like,
look here is a Black man
who work with Black men
in the church and you know,
really was able to
address some of the things
that may not be as heavily stigmatized
as having a substance use disorder,
but ain't nobody talking about depression.
Like that really just came
within the last decade,
really heavy in the last five years.
So Sidney was doing this
work before then, right?
So having that like blueprint
truly to be able to say like,
look, somebody has already done it in
this behavioral health space.
We can use a lot of the
work to already show what
is the most important, being
able to partner with community
to get buy in.
Similarly, I was very
comfortable in the church 'cause
I was raised in a Black Baptist church.
So I knew how to first
giving all glory to God.
(Sidney laughs)
- All glory to God.
- It was just like that is who I am.
They saw, this is important,
but I'm not just here to,
you know, advance in my
career and say deuces.
Like I literally joined
Varick even before the pastor
who is here now, Pastor
Steele, like anyway,
I was there right?
When we were looking for LatinX churches
to think about how do we
provide telehealth medication
for addiction treatment?
I like went out to the church,
figuring out like I know
I can't be the vessel.
I need to really work
with my LatinX brothers
and sisters who are actively
using drugs and say,
can you help me figure out,
like what are the churches that are cool,
that you feel safe with?
Cause every church ain't a church
that the pastor's gonna be
okay with having addicts.
I would never say that, but you know,
that's what people say, come
into the church for care.
- That's right.
- So really elevating those
voices in the community
and they showing me and
putting, can we talk about this?
Okay.
Me, these institutions don't
wanna pay community partners.
And so my thing is,
how can I use mine now?
I do have a little bit of power
to say to a place like NYU
or say to a place to
Yale, you gotta pay people
and not pay 'em for no
community advisory board,
pay them so they can pay their bills.
- [Sidney] That's right.
- Because what Sidney was
saying now we're thinking
about social justice is not just the tool
of accessing in my case,
substance use treatment
in the church, which
has been revolutionary,
and I'm super excited
because we're showing
that people are showing
up in the churches more
than they are traditional
addiction clinics
and that's just facts.
But also saying that for
people who are working
as community investigators,
I really think about them
as CO-Is on the project.
How to then do we set up a blueprint again
for economic security?
So that you are not just
worried about getting $500
for a community advisory board,
but this is a role you have expertise,
you can put it on your CV,
trainings you can get
so that you can advance
your own career so that you
can really support your family.
Right, so now when people are thinking,
how do they work with the
Jordan Wellness Collaborative
for community programs
and faith-based settings,
I'm like, how can I hire you
through the institution so
you can have benefits.
- Yep, that's real.
- Right, and so that's the
conversation I'm having now
and it's awesome.
It's awesome.
And I think part of it is
because I say like I can't sing,
the Lord knew that if he
gave me a singing voice,
I'd be out of control.
Shout out to my sister who
has the most amazing voice.
Aisha, I love you.
And what are my talents?
I'm really starting to see
as I get older that my talent
is bringing people along
and shepherding people
to understand that this work partnering
with faith-based communities
and other kind of community
organizations can be a way
for restorative healing.
- That's transformative.
I mean, everything you just mentioned too,
all the way across the board.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- And both are, I mean, just partnering
and elevating the voices,
making sure that people's
needs are being met.
I mean, I think that's just not
the way things have been thought about.
- Yeah, and what Ayana is
talking about ultimately
is, you know, transforming
generations, right?
When you're getting folks jobs
at our academic medical centers
and getting them benefits,
often that comes with
educational benefits, right?
You can take a class, you can do this.
Your kids can have access
or do access to school.
So I mean, this is
generational change what Ayana
is talking about.
And I think that is the
great next frontier.
It's not how can we
just elevate the voices
of our community members,
but how can we empower them, employ them
and then deploy them and
disseminate folks out,
you know, nationwide.
So this is critical.
- Okay, wait a minute.
I heard a serious word now.
(both laughing)
Cause the listeners,
- I like that too.
- cannot see because I
always will have a message
and a saying or something.
Now I, and I will give you credit.
I'm not gonna be a colonizer
and just take it for my own.
But Sidney came with a serious word now.
He said, "empower, how do we
empower people, employ them
and then deploy them!"
That's awesome.
I never even, and I'm going to
take it with your permission,
Sidney because,
- Sure.
I love that.
Right, really.
- That needs to be our
motto in New York City.
Seriously, Ayana, I'm so
excited to work with you.
We're doing it Sidney!
- We gonna do the thing, you know,
we are gonna do the thing, so.
- I already wanna work with them,
The H.O.P.E. Center at FCBC.
- And they gonna be right
around the corner from you.
- Hello, I was like, lemme
reach out to Sidney 'cause
I see he's already up in this thing.
So I need an intro.
- For sure.
Absolutely.
And so we are actually gonna
be starting, psychiatry
residents are gonna be there
for a year starting this fall from Sinai.
So I mean.
- Maybe we can say a little
bit about the H.O.P.E. Center
for people who don't know.
- Sure, yeah.
- So The H.O.P.E. Center
is a freestanding mental health clinic
that was birthed out of the
vision of Michael Walrond,
Pastor Walrond from First
Corinthian Baptist Church.
It's been open since 2016.
It provides 10 sessions of
free evidence based counseling.
So the providers there provide, you know,
trauma focused CBT,
interpersonal psychotherapy,
you know, problem solving therapy.
And then they can connect
people to longer term treatment
who need it.
But it's much more than just, you know,
providing direct care.
They also have like wellness fairs.
They provide spaces for yoga, for Reiki,
for all different types
of healing circles.
So they tap into, you know,
the breadth of the diaspora
and all that we provide
in terms of healing.
And I just really wanna
shout out Pastor Walrond.
He is a brother who is just
tremendously transparent
about his mental health journey
and the fact that he sees a pastor.
And I wanna shout out Dr. Lena Green,
who is the Executive Director
of the H.O.P.E. Center.
She is amazing at program
design and implementation.
So Ayana, you are there.
Yeah are there.
- Thank you because it's just so exciting.
I really think it's God's
plan for now Sidney and I
to both be in the city,
both be in places where
we're able to elevate
this faith based work because
I found out about FCBC because
a good girlfriend of mine
who lives in Harlem was like,
"Ayana, don't you do faith based stuff?"
She's a adolescent medicine doc
and she goes to church there.
- Awesome.
- And she sent me their
information and I'm like,
this is awesome.
And I couldn't believe it.
And then I found out
that Sidney was involved.
I'm like done and done.
I didn't even know about
the psychiatry residents
because I'm thinking,
can we provide access to MAP
because they're right in Harlem
in a place that doesn't have
easily accessible medication
for addiction treatment.
When we know Black
people, especially, right,
have extreme rates of accidental
overdose from this crisis
and we're being totally left behind.
So anyway, I was like,
can we expand to have FCBC
be one of the sites where
we provide telehealth MAP
for free?
- I would love for us
to do that, absolutely.
So we, I will definitely connect you
to Dr. Green, absolutely.
- Making connections on
the "Addy Hour!" (claps)
You didn't even know you were
bringing us together, see.
(all laughing)
- You almost had me amening
while you were all talking
about the deployment.
(all laughing)
And I mean, yeah,
definitely Pastor Walrond,
Dr. Green for listeners, if you haven't,
check out episode five,
because both of them were
on that episode talking
about the H.O.P.E. Center,
all the work that they've
done, like you mentioned,
Pastor Mike is just still
transparent about his story
and his journey with mental health
and how that facilitates
so many different things
in the congregation, in the community.
So, wow, this is full circle
and I love making these connections.
Now you're gonna get
me sharing stories too.
(both laughing)
So another episode, episode four
with Dr. Alfiee Breland-Noble.
- Of course.
- And Doug Middleton, who's an NFL player.
That was the first time they met.
They had a great episode.
They just met in person for
the first time at an event,
suicide prevention event.
So it's just, you know,
see that was another full
circle moment, you know,
just being able to
introduce the two of them,
the work that they're
doing in the same space
and just how much respect
they have for each other.
And I mean, for me, it's just,
I'm getting off topic here,
but it's encouraging to see the way
that people have been able to
come together on this podcast.
I mean, you know, we're 30 episodes in,
that's something like 60 different guests
and people working in different spaces,
they're doing so much important work.
And, you know, being in academic
spaces is so easy for us
to be in silos.
We do that really well.
So as much as we can connect people,
keep these conversations.
Even the ways that you
all did that organically.
And I would say divinely orchestrated,
and the ways that you all started,
I think is such an important
example for all of us.
And now I'm getting even
getting back to that, you know,
deployment aspect,
as people are going out into the community
or in the community coming
into these university settings,
going back out into the community.
And as much as we can
continue to foster all
of that engagement and communication,
I think it's just, it's critical.
I don't even know how to
put it all into words,
but I'm just kind of running
along with the vision
that you all are casting
if I can use that word.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, I think you
said it just brilliantly
and I think, you know, in
thinking about what is next,
right.
And I think that, not I think,
I know that Sidney has
already put it out there
with this empower, employ and deploy
because I think what really
is next is really thinking
about how to not only just
elevate community voices,
but put them in positions
where they're able
to live, right, to eat, as the kids say,
I don't know if the kids say
that anymore to eat, to live,
to take care of themselves.
I'm so old now.
I mean, I think I'm
cool, but then my nephew
who he's turning 12 at the end of,
shout out to little Lawrence, I love him.
Anyway, I said something, I don't know.
I used some slang.
I was like, "oh, this is so dope."
Or something like that.
He was like, "can you
please not say that, like."
(both laughing)
- Don't try.
- Like, don't try, you're not cool.
But the point is,
is really thinking about how do we go
and underscore what Sidney is saying,
really think about
generations and legacy, right?
That's the whole point.
And allowing people to have a way
towards advancing themselves
through this work.
And it's just restorative.
And so I'm just so grateful
for you Addy and this podcast,
because I think that you are
bringing people together.
Like you said, breaking
down those silos so
that we're able to move
in a way that allows us
to do this research differently.
- Yeah.
- We weren't taught this.
They weren't teaching about this,
you know, in my PhD program
or in medical school.
- Not at all.
- Yeah.
You all are leading the way.
And I hope that others are gonna
be able to continue to walk
with you as you all are elevating voices
and bringing leaders.
I mean, it's the next
generation of leaders
in a lot of ways too.
So I know our time is coming to a close.
That was way too fast.
But this, I mean, this was
a restorative conversation
to steal that word from you, Ayana.
Just again, I mean,
I know about the work that you all doing,
but to hear you talk about
the journey into the work
and then just the encouragement
and the vision of things going forward.
It's just to me, it's so important
in the midst of everything
we're continue to experience.
I mean, you all are, you
are out doing the work
and it's so important and so needed.
So I'm grateful to both of you.
I hope that the listeners will, you know,
get a chance to even re-listen to this,
think about all the different
aspects of wisdom that you,
the knowledge that you all have dropped
and just how important it is.
So greatly appreciate both of you.
Thank you for taking the time to be here,
especially with everything that you all do
with your schedules and
with how intentional you are
about taking time to rest too.
I don't take that for granted.
- Critical.
- And you made the space to be here.
So definitely appreciate you both.
- Love, love, love.
- Thank you, Nii.
- Of course.
(upbeat music)